c'est vrai que vous en avez plus riches
mais à contrecoeur total pendant une
semaine je me suis dit est ce que je le
fais ce que je le fais parce que je le
fais oui mais il faut que je le fasse
oui mais je sens que je dois pas le
faire et au final mark mays d'ailleurs
le maintenir ouais je l appelais les
gens les plus érudits
savais pas et puis au final je me suis
dit bon bah voilà je le fais et oui je
pense que ce n'était pas agréable ni
pour moi ni pour le docteur qui m'a
piqué parce que c'était vraiment un
moment très bizarre et d'ailleurs toutes
les personnes dans la salle m'ont
regardé en six ans mais est-ce qu'on
l'emmène à l'abattoir pour moi ce jour
là oui c'était pas décidé je n'avais pas
ma vie en main alors je voulais juste
vous demander par sans amour sans vie en
mains du groupe
secondes vous avait minimisé enfin vous
faites que demi selon les les comment
dire les effets secondaires les effets
secondaires alors hier j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages suite à l'émission
justement est une personne m'a dit voilà
mon père est mort d'une thrombose à la
suite du vaccin le problème c'est que je
pourrai pas lui rendre justice donc ça
c'est un message qui m'a ému je pense
qu'il y en a gagné voilà j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages comme ça et après
il ya aussi quelque chose que je voulais
vous demander combien d'enfants
aujourd'hui qu'ils appellent coded sont
mort du co vide est ce que vous le savez
vous avez un jeu il ya extrêmement peu
de mort sur son rôle et si on peut
reprendre les séries américaines sur les
moins de 11 ans on a on a moins de
quelques dizaines de morts c'est très
faible en revanche en revanche on a des
syndromes poli viscéraux qui sont
relativement préoccupant et on se
demande s'il y aura pas des conséquences
à long terme sur les organes qui sont
lésés mais effectivement il ya eu deux
morts chez les enfants de moins de 12
ans ce qui est sorti du lot peu de mort
des enfants qu'ils ont eus le covin
maintenant je veux poser une question
est ce que vous savez le nombre de morts
d'enfants qui ont été d'abord vacciner
ben non
il ya eu 20 signalement donc du pneu
ce sont des enfants qui sont morts
d'autres choses que du vaccin en tout
cas il ya eu des signalements se sont
élancés que je me dis c'est qu'il faut
peut-être penser que le bénévolat liste
rasées après le vaccin les bénéfices
risques pour les personnes âgées est
positif le bénéfice risque pour les
enfants ne l'est peut-être pas qu'il
évalue à tanger med et a déjà joué comme
imposer sa mère les médias eu 20
signalement des joutes à dire que c'est
pas juste mais oui des piles à léo
quelqu'un qui dit non mais c'est bon
c'est bon tu gardais c'est laurent moi
y'a quand mon char lan et ya quand même
quelque chose qui m'étonne vraiment
c'est que je trouve que vous êtes un
propagandiste change comprends mais je
trouve que vous minimisez grandement la
terreur la peur terreur qu'ont les gens
par rapport aux effets secondaires vous
évincé ça à chaque fois une paralysie
faut plus regarder en terme de com
genève a évacué jeudi que quasi génie
est embêtant c'est que ce souvenir c'est
totalement temporaire on évoqua différé
frostfell jacob très grave j'ai la gorge
on évoque tu les époux moussa c'est pas
vrai et vente est si fier au large et
moi non on évoque des dominos on évoque
des thromboses et à chaque fois on nous
dit oui mais bon alors finalement c'est
rien mais c'est pas rien on est content
avec cela sera gênée qu'à et tu sais
bien qu'on le l'astra ces cas
aujourd'hui on la route quasiment retiré
du marché français et on a donné le
match j'avais dit que c'était formidable
on dit que c'est formidablement le
vaccin à une maison déjà les meilleurs
c'est décalé géraldine maillet par
exemple qui nous regardent allez allez
allez vaccine à strasbourg